avec ses forêts privées il n'est pas
toujours évident de découvrir la sologne
et ses animaux sauvages pour permettre à
tous de découvrir sa richesse le domaine
de siran a ouvert ses portes il ya 40
ans il est au coeur de notre page était
ce soir on retrouve en direct arnaud
moreau sur place bonsoir arnaud bonsoir
et ce n'est pas les quelques nuages qui
vont nous empêcher de profiter de la
sologne ses magnifiques paysages cette
faune et cette flore incroyable alors on
a pu se balader ce matin dans le domaine
du si arrange vous propose de suivre
avec nous cette balade et ses surprises
à reportages réalisés avec isabelle
racine et jean guéguéniat un vent léger
souffle sur la sologne sans troubler son
calme en cette fin d'été
tout est encore bien vert quelques
champignons font leur apparition et les
bruyères permettent aux abeilles et
bourdon se régaler voici un aperçu de ce
que peut être la sologne territoire de
5000 m² méconnu et parfois inaccessibles
au public
c'est notamment pour ça que le domaine
du cir en a ouvert ses portes
la grande particularité de cette région
naturelle c'est qu'elle est rivé sur
près de 95% du territoire
donc l'objectif de l'association était
de pouvoir avoir des endroits
accessibles au public et sans que les
visiteurs à y n'importe où se promener
en sologne sur ses propriétés et voici
l'un des clous de la visite
la découverte d'animaux ici les cervidés
il évolue sur une surface de 8 hectares
je crois qu'ils sont encore assez
sauvage alors ça c'est quand même rare
qu'on voit ça et aussi la dynamique de
la groupe cintrée s'en va
ils viennent facilement au contact des
visiteurs mais ça reste quand même des
animaux sauvages et nous arrivons dans
la période du brame du cerf la période
de la reproduction et donc le cerf va
commencer à donner quelques signes
d'agressivité donc passerait de paille
au delà nous ne rentrons pas dans le
parc 1 le domaine se veut une belle
vitrine de la région l'appel même des
agneaux solognot une race très ancienne
qui avait failli disparaître ses moutons
ou un rôle de défricheur de
débroussailleurs et donc au 19e siècle
qui avait énormément de boutons plus de
800 mille moutons en sologne et nous
avons donc souhaité reconstituer ce
petit élevage pour faire de l'éco
pastoralisme c'est à dire de l'entretien
des espaces naturels sensibles par les
animaux le domaine fait actuellement ses
40 ans les occasions sont nombreuses
pour venir le visiter assisté au drame
du service septembre ou encore observer
les champignons en octobre et pour
parler justement du domaine du ciron
nous sommes avec olivier g fois que j'ai
froid le président de l'association pour
la fondation sur logne bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous bonsoir merci d'être au
domaine du suran ce soir et on a vu que
c'était un domaine qui permettait aux
touristes aux solognot mais pas
seulement de découvrir ce qu'est la
biodiversité c'était vraiment ça le
butin s'était créé une sorte de
catalogue de vitrine de la sologne
je dirais plutôt un conservatoire de la
faune et de la flore de sologne 777
les pères fondateurs les acteurs locaux
de sologne avec des fonds du ministère
de la culture et de la région ont acheté
ce domaine
300 ha pour les mettre à la disposition
de tous et de toutes
pour mettre à la disposition de cette
sologne magique magnifique alors qu'elle
est ailleurs a laissé cloisonné
malheureusement comme derrière nous il
ya des moutons il ya toute une faune
spécial c'était c'est vraiment une
démarche que qu'avait été choisi de
mettre en valeur toute cette faune à
c'est vraiment une démarche
environnementale une démarche de mise à
la disposition du plus grand nombre à la
fois de la faune et de la flore de deux
soleils alors il vous avez vu sans doute
dessert les moutons de sologne et puis
par ailleurs vous avez toutes les
espèces qu'on peut trouver en sologne
des espaces remarquables naturel les
gens qui viennent vous voir ce sont des
solognots ce sont des gens qui viennent
de pourquoi pas de toute l'europe alors
ce sont d'abord des gens de la région
ont des amis du loiret delwart est un
qui viennent aussi rang sur les 25000
visiteurs la part la plus importante
c'est celle là
le deuxième groupe le plus important ce
sont des gens qui viennent plutôt de la
région parisienne et qui viennent
s'oxygéner singulièrement les week-ends
et puis le troisième groupe s'est
beaucoup d'européens mais d'honneur
européens comme par exemple nos amis
hollandais
alors un petit mot sur les quarante ans
je crois qu'il ya un événement le 15
septembre parlez nous un peu de ce qui
va se passer ou est très important donc
nous fêtons en 2017
le no 40 ans le 15 septembre vendredi
prochain un grand concert de trompes de
chasse ici et à cette occasion je
signerai aussi avec le président du
département un contrat espaces naturels
sensibles qui va donner un petit coup de
pouce aux espaces naturels du domaine et
on va pouvoir par exemple rénover des
étangs les curés renforcer les digues
créer un parcours de pêche derrière moi
ici voilà pour que nos amis le plus
grand nombre puisse venir profiter nos
espaces et bien merci donc un programme
un programme très chargé donc pour ses
40 ans et je crois qu'une fois la
fréquentation est en hausse ont parlé
tout à l'heure de 40 % de fréquentation
en plus sur cette année voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire sur le domaine du cir en
faillite merci arnaud moreau prochain
épisode de la page et et demain à 19
heures